Вже майже 10 мільйонів українців
обрали своїх сімейних лікарів та підписали угоду про надання послуг.
Один з головних принципів медреформи:
що б не сталося зі здоров'ям, спершу - до сімейного лікаря.
Вже цього місяця перші лікарні почнуть
отримувати фінансування за принципом "Гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Тобто чим більше пацієнтів у сімейного лікаря, тим більший його дохід.
Держава виділятиме приблизно 370 гривень на дорослого і
740 - на дитину чи пенсіонера.
Максимально лікар зможе отримати
62 тисячі гривень на місяць.
Але це не чиста заробітна плата.
З отриманої суми ще доведеться сплатити зарплату медсестрі,
закупити медикаменти та медобладнання.
За даними МОЗ, вже підписали договори з Національною службою здоров’я
149 комунальних та 12 приватних медзакладів.
До кінця цього року всі медичні заклади
первинної допомоги мають це зробити.
Якщо хтось ще не встиг до 1 липня підписати угоду з лікарем,
його все одно повинні приймати лікарі.
Адже усі лікарні продовжують отримувати бюджетне фінансування.
А це вже сплачені українцями податки і їхнє право на медичні послуги.
До кінця року діятиме подвійний механізм.
Держава платитиме медзакладам за пацієнтів,
які підписали декларації з лікарями.
А також додатково по 240 гривень за пацієнтів, які
проживають на території обслуговування медзакладу,
але ще не підписали декларацію про вибір лікаря.
У МОЗ нагадують: ваш дільничний терапевт може попросити вас
обрати саме його і підписати з ним угоду.
Але це не обов’язково.
Вже були випадки тиску на пацієнтів і погроз з боку лікарів.
Це порушення закону.
Кожен сам обирає свого сімейного лікаря.
З 1-го липня лікарні вже мають працювати за новими стандартами.
Почав діяти новий перелік послуг,
які українцям мають надавати сімейні лікарі, терапевти та педіатри.
У МОЗ наголошують, що ці послуги - на 100% безоплатні
для кожного пацієнта, адже вони вже профінансовані з податків.
Отже, не потрібно платити, зокрема,
за загальний аналіз крові та сечі, холестерин,
електрокардіограму, швидкий тест на вагітність.
Також безкоштовні консультації з будь-яких проблем зі здоров’ям,
супровід пацієнтів із хронічними захворюваннями.
Крім того, серед обов’язків вашого лікаря -
вакцинація, профілактичні огляди, візити додому,
щоправда, за рішенням лікаря, а також
рецепти на ліки та медичні довідки.